[Music]
[Applause]
do you have a poll question Seton is it
Aaron Rodgers Jets related
well we could go with an Aaron Rodgers
one I have another one that I'm more
interested in though although we haven't
spent much time talking about it just
yet okay we'll save that one then yeah
all right again it's fine here's one
it's kind of a vague poll question
should the Packers do the right thing
and take a nice trade offer now
or Hardline this thing as Rogers is on
his way out
well they could do the right thing but
then the Jets have to do the right thing
and give them I don't want to put all of
this on the Packers like hey do the
right thing right I guess what I'm
saying is if you do the Packers are you
cut throat about this on the way out
completely cut throat and say we do not
care anything about our former Legend on
the way out we're gonna get everything
we can from okay well I'll ask Peter
King Peter King football morning in
America columnist proud member of the
Ohio U Bobcats fan club and uh Pete
showing system all right Pete what
should or will the Packers ask for from
the judge for Aaron Rodgers the only
thing that makes sense is one solid
draft choice now
and I believe solid equals a second
round draft pick now okay okay
and then a draft pick most likely in 25
that is conditioned on Aaron Rodgers
playing football for the New York Jets
in 2024.
and if he doesn't then the Jets uh would
uh you know then the compensation in
2025 would just be a second round pick
the only reason I'm saying this Dan you
compared it to Matthew Stafford not
really apples and apples Stafford's 33
years old at the time of that trade
actually he's a weak shy of 33 at the
time of that trade and for all anybody
knows he's going to play five or six
more years Aaron Rodgers is going to be
40 years old this season this will be
his age 40 season
and he he is so flighty and
unpredictable about his future that you
truly he might say today yeah I'm in for
at least two years hopefully three but
if he only plays one year for the Jets
it seems a little bit ridiculous to say
we'll give you two ones or we'll give
you one and a two
the way the only way this trade makes
sense is to take something solid now
let's say a second round pick right now
and then if Aaron Rodgers plays football
in 2024 then the Jets owe uh the Packers
a first round draft choice yeah okay who
has leverage here
I mean Green Bay can play hardball for a
long time because now everybody knows
that Rogers is playing for the Jets
and you know the Jets to a certain
degree can play hardball too the only
problem is this you don't want this to
be a long National nightmare you want
Aaron Rodgers at the start of the
off-season program or soon after that to
be in your building getting to know
Garrett Wilson you know in Breeze Hall
and all of these guys who he's gonna
have to make beautiful music together
with if you're going to conquer
um you know probably the the conference
in NFL history that has the best depth
of quarterback in it it certainly is the
best I've ever seen yeah what stood out
the most from the interview
uh just the fact that
um you know that he wants to play for
the Jets
and that impressed me from this
standpoint there are a lot of people
when Brett Favre went to play for the
Jets 15 years ago believe me he wasn't
all excited about going to play for the
New York Jets at all okay now we got
excited and he started playing well and
until he hurt his arm uh two-thirds of
the way through the season he was
playing great
but it impresses me that Aaron Rodgers
wants to play with the New York Jets
I don't know if there's Spike did did it
feel like there was any spite there with
Rogers the Packers it felt like the one
thing that felt a little spiteful was
Rogers clearly saying look Adam schefter
had this story you know whatever six
weeks ago whenever it was you know
saying that I think there's a good
chance Aaron Rodgers is going to be
traded whatever his tweet said whatever
you know he reported but he was right on
the money
and there is no way I believe no way
that that came from Aaron Rodgers as you
could tell by who's my number bro
but and so how did Eric I don't know
what I I'm not gonna sit here and and
and on the record guess but I think we
can all figure out we all have our
suspicions that that that piece of
information did not come from Aaron
Rodgers so who knows but all I'm saying
is Rogers clearly
doesn't like the fact that the Packers
are out there spreading the fact that
hey there's a good chance I'm going to
be traded
um it sounds like that they had not
talked to him about that before that
broke now maybe they did but it sounded
like uh Aaron Rodgers had some hard
feelings oh you think the Packers put it
out there
I don't know who put it out there what
I'm saying is Rogers sounds very much
like he didn't put it out there and he
has said time and again
time and again that nobody in my Camp is
leaking to Adam schefter Ian Rappaport
so I'm just Dan I'm just guessing right
now just like anybody else would where
do you think that came from it doesn't
sound to me anyway like it came from
Rogers yeah but then there's the wish
list who leaked that
and the deal is done who leaked that I
don't know I'm guessing that came from
the Jets side of this thing it could be
it very well could be and look whatever
happens at the end of the day
you know eight years from now Aaron
Rodgers is going to be standing on the
field at Lambeau
uh getting a standing ovation from a
crowd that is a little bit ticked off at
him right now okay but he'll be getting
the standing ovation the exact same way
did you ever think that Brett Favre
would get a standing ovation in Lambeau
when he came in wearing Vikings purple
for two years do you ever think that had
happened there's a lot of people who
said he's dead to us yeah but then he
walked back in the stadium and he was a
Conquering Hero same thing will happen
with everybody is there any chance the
Packers are making a big mistake here
of course if Jordan love can't play then
obviously it's a mistake but you look at
the Packers Dan this is so much like
farv it is incredible do you know why
Ted Thompson in 2008 and Mike McCarthy
said to Brett Favre we need a decision
from you early in the off season
about whether you're going to retire or
whether you're all in because look the
Packers had gotten sick of Brett Favre
showing up for training camp and not
coming in for any of the mini camps
Brett Favre viewed the off season as the
off season that's exactly what Aaron
Rodgers has viewed it at in as in recent
years and so when you view something
like that the team is going to say we
need a guy who is all in and they've
seen enough and you know what Dan I put
this in my column a few weeks ago
just remember one thing when Aaron
Rodgers took over after sitting on the
bench mostly for three years
uh in Green Bay in 0.506 and 07. there
was much skepticism about whether he was
going to be a good quarterback in the
NFL it's the exact same thing with
Jordan three years with Jordan love the
same amount of experience which is
barely very much and a lot of skepticism
about Jordan love I don't know whether
Jordan love is going to be any good or
not how can you know but I can tell you
this 15 years ago today March 16 2008 no
one knew that Aaron Rodgers was going to
be great
Peter King he's the columnist football
morning in America a couple other things
here the Cowboys releasing Zeke Elliott
and I was wondering what they're going
to do at running back with Pollard's
injury is there a chance Zeke Elliott
could come back and resign with the
Cowboys
I suppose so but you know look and again
you're going to see the same thing now
that Alexander Madison has re-signed for
decent money in Minnesota that gives the
Vikings the ability to place significant
hard ball with Dalvin cook the fact is
in today's NFL running backs have an
extremely short shelf life I understand
why Austin Eckler is doing what he's
doing because he might only have one
more payday in the NFL running backs
come and go so quickly and the Cowboys I
think after citing that ridiculous
contract with Zeke Elliott they're even
they paid him 50 million dollars over
the last four years and they got they
got four years averaging like 1040
rushing yards a year he was a nice
running back he was not a dominant
running back that's why nobody wants to
pay running back Stan because if you pay
them real money you get often times
anyway you get a nice return but you
don't get you know a you know a Walter
Payton in his prime Barry Sanders return
the game just isn't structured that way
anymore
All Quiet on the Lamar Jackson front
I mean it looks like it but look no one
no team out there is going to advertise
if they have a breakfast meeting with
Lamar Jackson today because very simple
reason that they don't want to upset the
apple cart in their own building and I'm
not suggesting Atlanta or or anybody is
going to go meet with him but uh No
One's Gonna advertise that they're gonna
go meet with him to talk to him because
they have people in their own building
who they have to take care of and look
Dan I just don't think Lamar is going to
find a pot of gold I he might uh and but
I I get no indication
especially at the scouting combine I
couldn't find any team now again they're
not going to advertise that but even way
off the record I could not find a team
and you know nobody is talking enough
about the fact that Lamar Jackson in uh
the last two seasons started and
finished one game in December and
January you've got to take the injury
history into account if indeed the
Baltimore Ravens have offered him a
contract that includes 133 million fully
guaranteed over the first three years
I I mean personally Dan and I don't know
that that's true that's what Lamar
Jackson tweeted but I I think he should
run to sign it I just don't know how he
would do any better than that now he
might he might I might be wrong but
that's just my it's all I have right now
is an educated guess Baker Mayfield
lands in Tampa your reaction
short-term Band-Aid
one year
I mean one year I think they probably
would like to play Kyle trast some this
year to see if either of these guys can
be the long-term guy but I would suspect
uh it's going to be a rough year for
Tampa and they will be in the
quarterback draft Market in uh 2024. one
more item here it was in your column
Frank Reich has never coached a short
quarterback price young is 510 the odds
of Carolina taking Bryce young over CJ
Stroud or Anthony Richardson
it's even more Stark than that if you
realize this that as a quarterback coach
offensive coordinator head coach Frank
Reich has coached in the NFL for 17
years
six games of those 17 years six games
have been quarterbacked by a guy who's
six two or six three
all the rest of them all the rest of
them 16 and a half years his quarterback
has been 6'4 or taller
and so that's why I say I'm not saying
they're not taking Bryce young but I am
saying that's pretty interesting that's
like a uh you know a CSI clue or
something like that that interests me
but Dan you know I'll tell you one thing
if these people who on all teams
Personnel people
they should all call Bill O'Brien
because Bill O'Brien is uh if you talk
to people in the NFL who've talked to
Bill O'Brien he it is rare incredibly
High Praise about how he never noticed
his height
uh they never game planned around his
height and he got very few balls batted
down I think I think Bryce young very
well might be the first pick I don't
know that and it seems logical that that
the 6-3 guy CJ Stroud would be the first
pick over the 510 guy but we'll see
Pete always great to talk to you and
good luck with your brackets uh you have
Marquette winning it all yeah I mean you
know Dan you know what I did I stole
Nicole auerbeck's bracket
oh I don't know anything about college
basketball but I stole it she tweeted it
out the other day she said hey here's my
guess so I literally filled in her
bracket thanks Nicole auerbeck I mean
that's the first one I saw when I went
online so it's not I'm not taking this
real seriously but but I appreciate
Nicole auerbach's knowledge well you can
blame her if it doesn't go well well
look I don't have any hope of ever
winning anything in this I'm not too
concerned about it thank you Peter as
always okay Dan that's Peter King
football morning in America contributor
to football night in America on NBC
we'll take a break your phone call is
coming up play of the day up next